je voulais dit tout à l'heure le climat
toujours varié simplement les échelles
de temps de cette variation sont
absolument capital pour savoir si c'est
quelque chose de désagréable ou pas pour
prendre un parallèle tout de suite vous
avez deux manières de décélérer 200
km/heure à zéro quand vous êtes en
voiture
la première s'est appuyé sur la [ __ ]
de frein ça prend 10 secondes la
deuxième c'est de rentrer dans un mur ça
prend quelques millisecondes le résultat
est pas le même
eh bien c'est exactement pareil en ce
qui concerne les variations du climat le
climat varie il a toujours varié
simplement pour les variations qui sont
en train d'être mise en route en ce
moment la question cruciale est celle
des échelles de temps par rapport aux
variations spontanée du système le
climat peut varier pour plein de raisons
historiquement au quaternaire la
première raison pour laquelle le climat
a varié c'est que le système solaire
n'est pas un ménage à deux très
pacifique mais un ménage à 10 donc très
turbulent et en particulier la terre est
soumise à la traction des grosses
planètes du système solaire jupiter et
saturne un peu moins uranus et neptune
est donc l'ellipse que la terre décrit
autour du soleil n'est pas une ellipse
régulière et là des petites variations
au cours du temps et ses variations
c'est à la fois une variation
d'excentricité elle est plus ou moins
allongée et une variations de
l'inclinaison de l'axé de rotation de la
terre sur le plan de leurs beats et plus
ou moins inclinés est quelque chose que
vous allez comprendre tout de suite
c'est que si la que c'était parfaitement
perpendiculaire au plan d'orbites on
aurait jamais de saison l'insolation
serait la même tout au long de l'année
donc y aurait pas de saison plus là que
s'est inclinée sur le plan d'orbites
plus les saisons sont marqués cette
inclinaison est un des éléments qui
déterminent de manière capital l'entrée
ou pas en glaciation à l'ère quaternaire
il y en a d'autres mais celui d'un joue
de manière très forte donc le climat
varie encore il fallait tout varié ce
qui est en train de se passer à
l'entrepôt scène c'est à dire
aujourd'hui avec l'homme qui est devenu
un agent climatique c'est que l'homme
est en train de devenir la première
cause du mariage de variations du climat
à l'échelle du siècle
c'est ça qui est en jeu alors comment
est ce qu'on fait ça on fait ça en
augmentant un phénomène parfaitement
naturel qui est là depuis des milliards
d'années qui s'appelle l'effet de serre
l'effet de serre qui est un processus
qui a été identifié par fourier joseph
de son petit nom il ya deux siècles
maintenant enfin 1824 on y presque est
un effet qui est dû au fait que vous
avez dans l'atmosphère des molécules qui
sont parfaitement transparente au
rayonnement solaire incident
et parfaitement opaque au rayonnement
infrarouge émis par la surface de la
terre
si vous avez fait un peu de rayonnement
du corps noir avant de rentrer ici vous
savez que le spectre d'émission d'un
corps dépend de sa température alors le
soleil qui a une température de surface
à 6 lille calvin nous envoie
essentiellement du visible et
l'infrarouge proche la terre qui a eu
une température de surface qui est
proche de 300 kelvin et mais
essentiellement des infrarouges
lointains et bien dans l'air vous avez
plein de gaz
tous les gars stries atomique ou plus en
gros qui sont des gaz qui intercepte les
infrarouges terrestre donc la lumière du
soleil enfin où le rayonnement solaire
avec les infrarouges visible pardon non
visibles parce l'infrarouge proche passe
à travers l'atmosphère
- la part qui réfléchit par les nuages
la glace etc est absorbée par le sol et
le sol lui en réponse émet des
infrarouges dans des grandes gammes de
fin d'année dans les longueurs d'onde
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus importante
c'est infrarouges sont absorbés près de
la surface par les gaz à effet de serre
qui sont donc des opacifiant ou
infrarouge que l'atmosphère a en petites
quantités comme le père magalas de
potassium opacifie l'eau quand vous en
mettez dans une baignoire à paris avec
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
nous augmentons l'opacité de
l'atmosphère au rayonnement infrarouge
émis par la terre
donc ce que nous allons faire c'est que
nous allons confier l'énergie près du
sol et de ce fait augmenter la
température des équilibres du sol mais
nous allons également corrélativement
refroidir la stratosphère parce qu'il ya
moins d'énergie qui peut aller être
absorbées moins de rayonnement qui peut
aller être observé dans la stratosphère
et ça ça vous explique tout de suite une
chose très simple soit dit en passant
c'est que si vous avez une température
près du sol qui augmente et une
température de la stratosphère qui
diminue vous augmentez le gradient de
température dans l'atmosphère et donc
vous augmenter la puissance convective
de tout ce qui convainc qd je pense
qu'ils ont dit ça de tous les mouvements
convectifs dans l'atmosphère et donc les
orages les tornades les ouragans la
pompe aspirante devient plus puissante
donc c'est très logique que vous ayez
trouvé dans le dernier rapport du giec
que dans un monde qui se réchauffe la
puissance des ouragans va augmenter
c'est parfaitement normal c'est un truc
qui est attendu on se pose également la
question pour les orages et les tornades
comme je les dis juste avant ce
réchauffement climatique
il est donc provoqué par une
augmentation des gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère et segas peuvent
s'accumuler dans l'atmosphère notamment
le co2 pour une raison chimiques de base
c'est pas à vous que je vais apprendre
que le co2 est un oxyde dioxyde de
carbone s'est pas non plus à vous que je
vais apprendre que vous ne pouvez pas le
dissocier chimiquement sans apport
d'énergie
si vous tentez de faire pousser des
plantes dans un endroit dans un placard
pas éclairé ça marche pas bien
peut-être que vous avez fait
l'expérience c'est sûr que ça marche pas
donc la photosynthèse est un processus
endothermique vous avez besoin d'un
photon vous avez besoin d'un apport
d'énergie qui va vous dissocier la
molécule de co2 parce que la liaison est
très forte et d'une façon plus générale
tous les oxydes sur terre sont des
molécules très stable 1 tous les
minerais métalliques par exemple se
trouve sous forme d'oxydé lors que le
métal peut oxydé donc les oxydes étant
des molécules très stable une fois qu'on
a mis du co2 dans l'atmosphère il n'y a
pas de processus chimiques spontanée
d'épuration c'est la raison pour
laquelle le co2 peut s'accumuler dans
l'atmosphère c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
processus chimiques d'épuration vous
avez deux processus d'épuration l'un et
physique
c'est une dissolution dans l'océan ça se
fait à la surface de contact et un
équilibrage de pression partielle
c'est un processus physiques et en plus
c'est un processus qui est ralenti quand
le climat se réchauffe parce que la
capacité du ce2 de l'oat 10 août du co2
diminuent quand l'eau se réchauffe
donc c'est un puits qui va s'affaiblir
avec le temps
voire même qui pourrait se renverser et
vous avez un deuxième processus
d'épuration gensous d'en parler donc
c'est la photosynthèse donc le co2
s'accumulent dans l'atmosphère est une
constante de temps qu'il faut garder en
mémoire parce que c'est absolument
cruciales pour le débat sur le
changement climatique
si demain matin on arrête les émissions
dans le monde
demain matin on arrête les émissions
dans le monde et bien le surplus de co2
que nous avons créé il n'y en a que 60 %
qui sera parti dans un siècle il en
restera encore 20% dans mille ans et 10%
dans des bilans dont vous avez un
processus fondamentalement irréversible
en ce qui concerne le changement
climatique c'est comme le vieillissement
c'est fondamentalement irréversible je
peux pas me dire à mon âge
ah bah merde j'aurais pas dû faire
league sera dû faire l'agro ailleurs
pris 7 je me retrouve à 18 ans et je
change de voir ça marche pas d'accord
c'est ça marche pas donc le changement
climatique c'est exactement pareil
à cause de cette constante de temps de
du temps de résidence d'un surplus de
co2 dans l'atmosphère
il n'existe pas de possibilité de remise
en état du système
c'est une notion qui n'existe pas dans
le débat sur le changement climatique
donc si un jour comme petit gibus on dit
si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu trop
tard est la seule garantie que nous
avons dans ce débat la sole en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique c'est
que si un jour
l'expérience se met à nous déplaire pour
de bon la seule garantie qu'on aura à ce
moment là c'est plus tard ça sera pire
c'est important d'avoir ça en fait un
c'est parce qu'on n'est pas du tout des
animaux câblé pour être capable de
réagir à ce genre de problème parce que
je vous rappelle et vous le savez à
toutes les mensuels
nous sommes des animaux nous sommes des
animaux alors si je suis un tout petit
peu plus sérieux nous sommes des animaux
c'est à dire que nous sommes gouvernés
par nos sens
notre rapport à l'environnement se fait
au travers de nos sens
nous sommes innocents son court termiste
est instantané enfin immédiat et enfin
locaux et instantanée pardon donc mes
sens me permettent de dire quelle est la
température qui fait dans cette pièce
tout de suite mes sens ne permettent
absolument pas de dire quelle est la
température qui fait en australie à
l'instant où je vous parle
et encore moins la température qui
faisait en chopin ou à vladivostok à six
mois d'accord mais sens ne me permettent
pas de dire ça ma cervelle oui c'est
plus compliqué mais sans ce nom dans
tout ce qui relève de la moyenne du et
ses terrasses et pas avec nos sens qu'on
peut l'approcher c'est avec une approche
intellectuelle mais on n'est pas fait
pour ça et par ailleurs le mode
d'apprentissage qui a été le nôtre comme
tous les animaux qui sont gouvernés par
leur sens et un mode et ses erreurs
alors le bois d'essais et erreurs
fonctionne très bien dans les situations
réversible sauf pour les quelques-uns
qui font une erreur tellement grave qui
s'y passe voilà ça a toujours été le cas
dans tous les représentants d'une espèce
animale
de temps en temps et en a qui font une
expérience qui n'aurait pas dû faire
craquer 10 passes les autres le voit il
ajouté pas faire la même chose mais donc
vous avez un apprentissage de type
essais erreurs mais quand vous n'avez
pas droit à l'erreur
comment vous faites parce que dans cette
affaire là on aura qu'un seul essai donc
on n'aura pas droit à l'erreur
enfin obliger ctte mans si on s'est
trompé et c'est très très difficile ça a
l'air de rien dit comme ça mais c'est
très très difficile de lutter contre ses
sens et de faire prévaloir la partie
gauche ou droite je sais jamais de sa
cervelle c'est à dire celle qui vous a
permis de rentrer ici très difficile
donc le changement climatique est un
phénomène à très très forte inertie
alors pour vous donner quelque sorte de
grandeur sur ce que ça veut dire ce
changement climatique le premier ordre
de grandeur qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que 5 degrés que vous avez
évidemment en tête comme étant la
fourchette haute
pas maintenant on ne parle de 6 à 7 mai
du réchauffement climatique
en fait c'est la même chose que ce qui
correspond à une transition glaciaires
et interglaciaires donc quand la france
est passée d'un paysage qui ressemblait
au nord de la sibérie
il ya vingt mille ans à l'état qu'on lui
connaissait
dans l'ère préindustrielle et ont
presque encore maintenant il ya dix
mille ans eh bien le climat ne se
réchauffe et que 2,5 degrés sur la
planète donc 5 degrés en un siècle
c'est un réchauffement 100 fois plus
rapide que celui qui a vu l'océan
remontée de 120 mètres en dix mille ans
les écosystèmes devenir ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui alors qu'ils étaient ceux du
nord de la sibérie et une calotte de
glace de trois kilomètres d'épaisseur
posé sur la scandinavie et le canada
disparaître 5° en débit lent donc 5
degrés en un siècle c'est évidemment
quelques chiens c1 c'est un chaos c'est
un choc extrêmement violent
alors dans les évolutions qualitatives
auquel il faut s'attendre
d'abord il faut savoir que la
température va pas monter de manière
homogène l'inertie thermique des
continents et en plus faible elle
montera plus vite sur les continents que
sur les océans donc si vous avez un
réchauffement global de 2 degrés ce sera
3 sur les continents ensuite ça va pas
être vrai également pour les extreme iii
sur les continents ça veut dire 5 à 6
pour les extrêmes donc c'est pas du tout
proportionnelle cette affaire là la
deuxième chose qu'il faut savoir c'est
que le réchauffement climatique va
globalement augmenté l'évaporation donc
augmenter les précipitations
par contre la science la plus moderne
permet de dire deux choses c'est que ça
sera encore plus mal répartie qu'avant
c'est à dire ceux qui en ont beaucoup en
or ou encore plus et ceux qui en ont pas
beaucoup en auront encore moins et donc
dans ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup qui en
auront encore moins le pourtour du
bassin méditerranéen va s'assécher joue
si bien qu'on est dedans dhr donc nous
on est du mauvais côté de la barrière
dans cette histoire les anglais vont se
faire et non des plus souvent les
scandinaves aussi et la mousson sera
plus violente mais une mousson plus
violentes sur des sols plus sec
ça sera pas nécessairement très
intéressant pour les cultures indiennes
le lundi ce de sécheresse des sols va
augmenter dans nombre de zones et
notamment en france donc on a toutes les
chances en france d'ici 2050
c'est-à-dire quand vous aurez mon âge
que la sécheresse que nous ayons connu
cet été soit l'état moyen des sols en
france ça peut être terrible ça peut
être terrible hein jean brun qui lève le
sourcil ça va pas être terrible
il est évident que dans ce genre de
paysage une bonne partie des forêts
disparaissent parce que nous avons
aujourd'hui des arbres qui ont quand
même un peu besoin d'eau qui aime pas
trop quand il fait trop sac aime pas
trop quand il fait trop chaud et qu elle
pas trop les incendies non plus et par
exemple en 2050 la capacité de la forêt
de fontainebleau a développé des
incendies sera la même que celle des
landes aujourd'hui dans les autres
joyeusetés auquel il faut s'attendre
l'océan va monter on le sait on va
monter pour deux raisons la première
c'est que quand vous chauffez l'ol se
dilate et donc si vous chauffer l'eau
qui est dans une grande baignoire sans
toucher au fond est bien le niveau de
l'eau monte mais c'est pas ça qui va
faire le plus monter l'eau ce qui va
faire le plus monter l'eau c'est
l'atteinte aux calotte polaire alors le
groenland a commencé à fondre
dès à présent et à partir de maintenant
vous n'avez que des rétroactions
positives qui vont amplifier la chose
la première rétroaction positive c'est
que comme vous le lisez probablement
dans la presse l'étendue de la banquise
a tendance à diminuer de plus en plus or
quand la banquise disparaît vous
remplacez une surface très
réfléchissante par une surface très
absorbante pour le rayonnement solaire
et donc la température qui environnent
la calotte groenlandaise a tendance à
s'élever encore plus vite la deuxième
chose c'est que la fonte de la calotte
et une fonte de surface c'est pas des
icebergs qui se déversent dans la mer
pour l'essentiel c'est une fonte de
surface après l'antarctique de l'ouest
est autre chose dans paris
comme c'est une faune de surface quand
le niveau quant à fond le niveau de la
calotte enfin l'altitude maximale de la
calotte baisse un peu et du coup vous
vous rapprochez d'un air ambiant qui est
un peu plus chaud puisque quand vous
descendez en altitude
vous savez que cause de la détente est
diabétique la température augmente et
donc la température environnante
augmente
dernier point la surface du groenland et
couverte de poussière qui sont amenés
par le vent quand vous êtes dans un
processus dans lequel vous avez
accumulation annuel de poussière mais de
neige qui recouvre la poussière c'est
pas grave mais quand la neige se met à
fondre
à ce moment les poussières sont
concentrés en surface et elle augmente
aussi d'albédo c'est à dire la capacité
d'absorption du rayonnement solaire de
la calotte donc à quai de rétroaction
positive dans cette affaire donc d'ici à
ce que l'humanité s'éteignent enfin non
quelques siècles le groenland va
continuer à fondre et ça c'est n'importe
quoi entre 3 et 6 mètres d'eau dans
l'océan
quelques siècles de l'autre côté il ya
une instabilité majeur qui a été mise en
lumière par la communauté scientifique
qui a maintenant quelques années qui est
celle de l'antarctique de l'ouest alors
l'antarctique de l'ouest
il n'y a pas de l'ouest en antarctique
puisque c'est centré sur le pôle sud
normalement l'antarctique de l'ouest
c'est la partie de l'antarctique qui
regardent le chili qui est en face du
cap horn vous savez avec cette espèce de
grand douala qui remonte vers le vers le
chili c'est une partie qui est détaché
de l'antarctique de l'est par 2 1 dans
passion qui sont les mer de ross et
devait d'elle et elle porte cette
antarctique de l'ouest une calotte qui
est posée sur un socle rocheux est
totalement sous marin en déclivité
et c'est un vaste système de glaciers en
arcs boutants les uns sur les autres et
les arcs boutants terminaux c'est les
glaciers qui se déverse dans la mer
alors tant que ces glaciers qui se
déversent dans la mer se déversent pas
trop vite ils jouent leur rôle d' arc
boutant par rapport aux glaciers qui
sont au dessus
à partir du moment où ces glaciers qui
se déversent dans la mer se déverse
beaucoup plus vite et c'est ce qui est
en train de leur arrivée en ce moment
les arcs-boutants finaux sont
fragilisées et tout peut s'écrouler
comme un château de cartes
en combien de temps il ya trois ans il
ya un papier qui a fait grand bruit qui
est sorti d'un sérieux en ce qu'ils
disaient en quelques siècles
dès qu'on a passé 2 degrés donc dès que
le réchauffement dépasse
dès que la terre est sur une trajectoire
de réchauffement qui dépasse les 2
degrés en 2100 ce qu'on est évidemment
partie pour faire et bien le risque de
déstabilisation existe et la science la
plus récente dit maintenant quelques
siècles on sait pas ça peut être plus
court que çà et là il y en a pour six
mètres dos
donc 6 + 3 plus la dilatation on est en
train de jouer en ce moment donc ça va
pas arriver la semaine prochaine mais le
doigt sur la gâchette s'est tout de
suite
on était en train de jouer en ce moment
avec dix mètres dos en plus dans l'océan
mondial 10 mètres dos en plus vous
n'avez plus une ville côtière vous avez
plus enfin si vous avez 10 villes
côtières surélevé donc si vous êtes en
haut de la deûle à la montagne où il ya
la bonne mère notre dame de la garde à
marseille
vous n'êtes pas inondée mais il ya plus
encore donc c'est parfait les routes
maritimes seront ouvertes parce qu'il ya
plus de banquise n'y a plus de pauvres
pour partir et arriver posera un petit
problème
vous avez énormément d'installation qui
sont situés en bord de mer et vous avez
évidemment ce que vous savez énormément
de plaine alluviale qui sont des
endroits majeur pour l'alimentation
humaine
le delta du nil le delta du gange enfin
je vous en passe et des meilleures donc
tout ça et bien avant que ça fasse dix
mètres ça sera salini zay à cause de la
pression osmotique parce que quand la
mer monte
ça vous sally's les nappes phréatiques
qui sont situées en dessous toujours
dans les joyeusetés vous allez avoir une
pression supplémentaire sur les
écosystèmes et enfin il faut bien voir
que la première pression sur les
écosystèmes ces 8 milliards de bronze en
1 de très très loin parce que la
première pression sur les écosystèmes et
la biodiversité c'est la perte d'habitat
est la première cause de perte d'habitat
c'est la suppression des écosystèmes
installé pour faire des cultures
donc on a deux problèmes si on aime bien
la biodiversité qui s'appelle la taille
de la population et son régime
alimentaire
donc on a deux sujets de préoccupation
si on aime bien la biodiversité qui
s'appelle le planning familial et manger
moins de viande
c'est à peu près ça le les déterminants
de la faire le toujours dans les
conséquences vous allez évidemment avoir
après des conséquences sociales et
politiques à large échelle alors dans le
dernier rapport du giec changement
climatique et terre qu'il a lu ici vous
êtes tous virés vous êtes à la grosse
vous avez pas lu ça scandale non mais je
plaisante pas si je plaisante mais quand
même c'est un scandale
si vous avez une lecture à avoir dans
l'école dans laquelle vous êtes c'est
celui là c'est celle là pardon donc
lisez le résumé pour décideurs
changement climatique et hertz a fait 35
pages vous devriez y arriver c'est
vraiment un truc est absolument crucial
compte tenu du de la filière qui est la
vôtre absolument crucial donc dans le
dernier rapport du giec changement
climatique et heures le giec 10 à partir
de 3 4 degrés de réchauffement il ya des
de l'insécurité alimentaire généralisée
sur la planète alors vous vous rappelez
peut-être de 1789
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
en 1788
ah ça c'est bien vous savez un demi
million à un million de morts vous avez
entendu parler du printemps arabe
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est passé
juste avant inflation alimentaire
intolérable c'est ça qui s'est passé
juste avant dans des pays qui sont en
insuffisance alimentaire locale cdp qui
sont obligés d'importer leur nourriture
l'égypte la tunisie 1 et ça va en
augmentant parce que le bassin
méditerranéen ça sèche alors que leur
population croît et les importations
agricoles ont des prix qui varient très
largement comme ceux du pétrole en 2010
très forte remontée des prix du pétrole
donc les pays qui importent de la
nourriture voient leur facture
alimentaire augmente et mai 2010 on est
dans l'after maaf 2 1 de la crise de
2009 et donc les touristes restent chez
eux donc les recettes à l'exportation de
ces pays l'egypte et la tunisie se sont
cassé la gueule moins de recettes plus
de charges on n'est pas capable de
compenser budgétairement enfin de
compenser le prix de la nourriture pour
les gens qui sont dans les trois quatre
cinq premiers déciles de revenus qui
vivent avec un dollar par jour et c'est
l'émeute
parce que ils ont pas de quoi s'acheter
à manger et en fait des émeutes de la
faim au moment où le prix du pétrole est
repassé par des sommets vous en avez eu
dans plein d'endroits dans le monde
alors aujourd'hui on est encore avec une
agriculture très productive des
combustibles fossiles de partout des
engrais est partout et c'est tout ça
n'est pas éternel il est évident que
quand vous aurez une agriculture avec
des sols plus sec et des intrants en
quantités moins disponible avec une
population censé être plus nombreuses
oui on est d'accord on lève le sourcil
une deuxième fois
c'est pas complètement sûr que tout ça
va être
un long fleuve tranquille et donc il ya
également des instabilités politiques
qui sont à la clé et donc dans les
risques du réchauffement climatique vous
en avez aussi un qui s'appelle la
dictature et même en france même en
france la démocratie en france c'est
récent pendant les milliers d'années que
notre pays a hébergé des hommes
il s'est passé un siècle en démocratie
d'accord donc c'est court et c'est pas
éternel je suis pas en train de dire que
je souhaite sa disparition
juste en train de dire c'est pas
éternelle parce que c'est un système
fragile et c'est notamment un système
fragile parce que c'est un système qu'on
termiste pendant qu'il a dit c'est
monsieur tong il ya deux siècles il
s'était pas trop trompé
donc voilà donc le changement climatique
c'est un processus à large échelle
l'insécurité sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique c'est aussi un processus à
large échelle alors je vais finir par ça
dans cette affaire-là donc à ce stade
vous avez compris plusieurs choses si on
a été capable de mettre tout le monde en
ville avec une agriculture très
productive c'est grâce à l'énergie
cette énergie fait que on a été capable
de monter à 8 milliards d'hommes bien
nourris raisonnablement sauf quelques
endroits sur terre parce que justement
on a été capable de rendre l'agriculture
beaucoup plus productive
alors que la terre n'a pas augmenté de
diamètre c'est toujours la même surface
qu'il ya des rides et continent n'a pas
fait apparaître une quantité de surfaces
cultivables supplémentaires majeur en
deux siècles
vous comprenez également qu' on a tout
ay sujet avec l'instabilité climatique
alors l'agriculture contribue soit dit
en passant au réchauffement climatique
puisque dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre à peu près un tiers si je
prend en compte la déforestation vient
du secteur agricole alors les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre concernés vous
les trouvez dans la déforestation
c'est 10% sur 30% et le reste c'est les
émissions au folie's l'émanation plus
exactement de méthane des rizières
vous savez dans les rizières vous avez
de la décomposition anaérobie de résidus
organiques à l'abri de l'oxygène de
l'air ça vous fait du méthane comme dans
les marécages
c'est la fermentation entérique des
bovins les cochons ont quatre estomacs
dégueulasse sauf quand on en fait des
tripes et c'est les déjections animales
pour partie et enfin c'est la réduction
des nitrates qui s'opèrent quand vous
épandez des engrais azotés dans les
champs et chivu produit un gaz qui
s'appelle le n2o du protoxyde d'azoté
qui est aussi le gaz qu'on vous a
peut-être fait respirer quand vous étiez
gamin l'hôpital st gall hilarant qui est
un anésthésiant léger donc l'agriculture
au travers de toutes ces émissions là
contribuent au réchauffement climatique
et les émissions directes du secteur
agricole c'est 20 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre c'est autant que les
centrales à charbon dans le monde donc
ce n'est pas complètement négligeable
c'est peut-être moins comment dire c'est
peut-être plus indispensable que les
centrales à charbon soit dit en passant
mais c'est quand même 20% donc
l'agriculture un lien avec l'énergie et
le changement climatique qui est
extrêmement intime un sa productivité
vient de l'énergie le fait qu'on ait pu
mettre les gens bien nourris dans les
villes c'est l'énergie l'agriculture
contribue au changement climatique et le
changement climatique
en retour va faire du mal à
l'agriculture globalement donc voilà le
paysage dans lequel on est et comme j'ai
pas de slide je m'arrête là
donc maintenant place aux questions et
la bonne question évidemment c'est
qu'est ce qu'on fait